this Cascade of mud swept away
everything in its path and left a trail
of Destruction in its wake
heavy rainfall caused flooding and
triggered a landslide on the Italian
Holiday Island of iskia in the early
hours of Saturday morning
I had three shops all next to each other
selling household appliances Christmas
items I've lost everything in this
tragedy who could have known I don't
know what to say we need help
the mud cut through the port of Casa
michola on the north of the island
washing cars and buses into the sea
buildings were destroyed streets left
impossible and many homes demolished
around a hundred people were reportedly
left stranded some still unaccounted for
rescue efforts are underway with
reinforcements ferried onto the island
but emergency services are being
hampered by more bad weather
there are difficulties in the rescue
operations because the weather
conditions are very challenging we're
sending teams both by air and sea I'm in
close contact with prime minister
Georgia Maloney and my fellow ministers
it's an evolving situation very serious
Italy is susceptible to landslides like
this and houses often don't meet safety
regulations with warnings of rainfall
and strong winds still in place the
effort to clear the damage is just
beginning
the wounds to this town may take longer
to repair Siobhan Robbins Sky News